welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for a
presentation titled
characterization and selection of
antibodies for precision
diagnostics using via core surface
plasmin resonance
technology it's my pleasure to introduce
you
to anya drescher senior application
specialist
for biacore systems saitiva for a
complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen now if any questions arise during
the presentation
we encourage you to submit them into the
q a box our speaker will address your
questions following
the end of the presentation please join
me
in welcoming anya drescher i will now
turn the presentation
over to her welcome anya
thanks for joining and welcome to my
talk
about the characterization and selection
of antibodies
or other proteins for precision
diagnostics
using biacore sbr technology
for all precision diagnostic essays you
see here
just some examples defined detector
molecules are needed
nato provides us with numerous examples
of such detectors
like cell surface receptors that binds
hormones or growth factors
all the well-known antibodies you see
here each of them
recognizing individual antigens which
can range from tumor markers
to virus spike proteins
the proper selection of such binding
molecules
allows you to develop sensitive and
selective diagnostic assays
even for use with very complex
biological samples
for a successful diagnostic essay the
detector molecule
must fulfill certain biophysical
characteristics
which are very individual for biological
molecules and can't be
theoretically predicted they need to be
measured
the detailed analysis of binding
properties and behavior
of the detector molecule can guide your
selection
and support the quality control over the
complete lifespan of a diagnostic assay
what are these characteristics of a
perfect detector molecule
first of all the detector needs to be
specific
for an individual binding site on the
respective analyte
to not cross-react with other molecules
in your sample
a very stable complex should be formed
because the signal will last longer and
such complexes will be resistant to
washing steps in the essay
a fast binding is advantages since it
allows
short incubation times for the essay
and finally the binding of a perfect
detector
should be insensitive to various
reduction
conditions which questions need to be
answered during the detector selection
process first of all define
what should be detected are there may be
special details for the analyte known
you need to take care of
what kind of sample will the essay face
is there a potential sample matrix
interference
on the binding reaction what is the
necessary sensitivity
and specificity which diagnostic essay
format is planned
since you might need antibodies which
recognize different epitopes on the
antigen in question
which temperature range the sa will face
during storage
or when the analysis is performed
and how stable is the detector molecule
activity
during production purification and
storage
if you can measure the lot to lot
variability of the detector activity
you can adjust the concentration applied
in your assay production
accordingly
all of these questions on the
characteristics of a perfect detector
molecule
can be answered with biacore spr systems
biological interactions are real-time
binding events
where molecules associate with
or dissociate from each other
biacore systems enable real-time
label-free monitoring
of these biological interactions
what are the benefits of biacore sbr
systems
they employ a label-free detection
system so no
labels are required and therefore they
can measure
binding properties of unmodified
substances
resulting in save of time and workload
on sample preparation
vehicle systems measure in real time so
you can observe
binding as it happens and this provides
unique information on binding rates
as association and dissociation rates
are time dependent processes
they can be only determined with a
real-time analysis
in addition real-time analysis allows
observation of transiently existing
complexes
as well as stable ones
systems have a contact-free detection
system
which means the detecting light beam
does not pass through the sample
so direct measurements of opac or
colored samples
with loss of sensitive without loss of
sensitivity and accuracy
are possible and you can work with crude
samples
like serum or cell extracts
b ecosystems have three core components
for detection of molecule interactions
in real time
so first the sensor chip which is a
variable part depending on the
application that should be investigated
and this sensor chip is inserted to the
biacore instrument
they have a microfluidic system for
automated handling
of low sample volumes and
a surface plasmon resonance detection
unit
the so-called sensogram depicts the
binding response
observed over time one interaction
partner which we call the ligand is
attached to the sensor surface chip
inserted to the biaco instrument buffer
is flowing over that surface
giving us a baseline response
the sample containing the other
interaction partner
the so-called analyte is passing over
that surface and if binding occurs
the mass on the surface increases which
will be recognized
by a increase in response
of the sbr detection signal
here this system switches back to buffer
passing over the surface
and you can then observe how fast the
complexes which have been formed
how they decay from the surface
there are several readouts possible from
bioco essays
specificity how specific is the
interaction
for one or the other analyte which you
will recognize
if there is a binding response or not
concentration how much of a given
molecule is active
because only the functional molecules
show the respective binding
and binding kinetics can be determined
how fast or slow does the complex form
or decay
such a kinetic characterization of
biological interactions
can guide the selection of best-in-class
detector molecule
how does this work we see here an
overlay of two interactions
showing the same steady state affinity
but significantly different
kinetic rate constants
which you can recognize from the
sensogram shape
so here you see
a fast association for this interaction
and also a fast dissociation
so these complexes decay quite fast
direction here shows the flow slower
association
but the complexes when they have formed
they show a very stable
complex which decays very slow
you see it here in the slope of the
sensogram
in your selection process for the best
in class detector molecules
you should aim for a fast association
rate
because then in your essay you can allow
short incubation times and with a fast
association rate you would also have the
advantage that binding occurs
already at lower sample concentrations
but even more important is that that you
aim for a slow dissociation rate
because this means the complexes which
are formed
are very stable the slower the
dissociation rate
the more stable are the complexes
and such stable complexes will withstand
several washing steps and incubation
times in the run of your essay
i will now present some case studies
which demonstrate how biacore spr
analysis was applied for detector
molecule selection
first of all a screening and
characterization of antibodies for use
with diagnostic devices
which is a collaboration with biomedical
diagnostics institute
at dublin city university in ireland
bdi develops next generation biomedical
point-of-care diagnostic devices
high-quality antibodies or antibody
fragments
are key components used in their
diagnostic
essays they have screened
diverse antibody libraries directed
against kinetically relevant biomarkers
of cardiovascular disease or
cancer with aim of the biacore
instruments
here you see an overview of bdi
screening workflow
they employ phage display to screen
their
single chain antibody fragment libraries
vdi has an automated primary screening
process
but the results of this initial screen
are of limited data quality
so with further detailed analysis was
essential
to identify good lead candidates
for single chain antibody fragments
which will be taken further
in the development step
for that purpose they screened their
single chain antibody fragments
with a biacore assay to speed up the
analysis
all single chain fragments were fused to
an hemoglotinine antigen
attack
an anti-hemoglotinin antibody
was immobilized on their surface
and so the single chain fragments with
the h8 tag
shown here in red so single chain
fragments are in blue here
this is the tech they could be captured
directly
from crude cell lysates on the surface
on the h a antibody
so different single chain fragments
could be
uh analyzed in each sa cycle so
in in the used system eight different
single chain fragments were screen per
essay cycle
and always one concentration of the
troponin
was passed over the samples and then
kinetics were investigated
and in this screen well plates of
single chain fragments specific to human
cardiac troponin 1
were screened
here you see the raw data the results
they got
from the screen of all these single
chain fragments
this is an overlay of all sense
sensograms from each of the clones
investigated
in one picture and they were focusing
for for the ranking of these clones
based on the complex stability
so they mainly looked here in the this
is on the dissociation phase
and they took report points early in the
dissociation
and after one minute which you see here
and the risk the difference of these two
responses
were used to calculate the percent
left amount and this number
indic allows a fast
selection of the most stable complexes
as you see here in this sensogram there
are some
which show a very stable binding so
there's almost
no signal difference between these two
report points here and there are others
like this one which decay very fast so
there will be a huge
difference in these report points taken
so this is a very fast and easy
identification possible
for clones which show the most stable
binding
the result overview overviews easily can
easily be seen
in such a plot where the the early
response
put here on the y-axis and the later
response after one minute of
dissociation
is plotted in this direction so
this line here shows 100 percent left so
it means there was no signal drop
over the run of this one minute
and the clones which are located here
close to the hundred percent left line
are the most
interesting ones because they are the
best binders showing the most stable
complexes
in this essay they have run 960 samples
within eight hours and the data
all the results could be evaluated in
less than two hours
the most stable signal chain fragments
were then rapidly identified
and used for further prioritization
so top ten percent were taken for an
additional kinetic characterization
because what they aim for is to get the
best in class
binders which show also a very
stable complex formation at
physiological temperatures
so for this purpose they investigated
kinetic rate constants
at 25 degree which would be similar to
what they have done in the screening
and they measured the same interaction
at 37 degree
shown here and this is one of the best
in class single chain fragments
which retained a quite stable
complex formation so a slow dissociation
also at physiological 37 degrees celsius
so a temperature stable high affinity
single chain could be quickly identified
for further testing
in bdi's diagnostic device platform
the next study looks at the impact on
the biochemical environment
on detector molecule binding this is a
collaboration
with scott clarcamp and andy drake from
upgenex
and david mishka
theorists of this study asked the
question
does the binding of detector antibodies
tolerate
varying buffer conditions and to answer
this
they investigated the binding behavior
under variable salt and ph conditions
and they employed such as such an essay
set
up so four different antibodies
were immobilized here in one flow cell
and the same set of antibodies also here
in these others so they had four four
flow cell with four
different antibodies and over each flow
cell
the antigen diluted in a buffer with
different conditions was passing over
that surface
so they could investigate four different
buffer conditions
at a time
you see here the results of the antibody
binding under various salt conditions in
the buffer
so here the kinetics of all these four
antibodies was investigated
with buffers containing 50 millimolar
sodium chloride
up to 600 millimolar sodium chloride
and the affinity change was observed
three of these antibodies
showed sequentially lowered affinity
just the monoclonal antibody 12 was
almost
unaffected by changes in salt
concentration
and here are the combined results for
salt and ph
effects on the binding of the four
investigated antibodies
this plot shows here the determined rate
constants
association rate and dissociation rate
for each of the measurements under the
eight
and the eight different running
conditions
and just monit the monoclonal antibody
12
shown here with the pink circle showed
the least buffer sensitive binding
and this antibody was then taken for
further
investigating in the diagnostic device
now i will show you how epitope binning
analysis
can be used for further differentiation
of diagnostic reagents
for the development of a diagnostic
sandwich assay
like the one shown here you need to
identify
antibody pairs which recognize
non-overlapping epitopes on the antigen
to be determined otherwise they cannot
bind to the antigen at the same time but
this is a prerequisite
for setting up such type of essays
the binding characteristics to be
screened for
have to be the same as for all perfect
detectors
epitope binning experiments with beer
core need minimal time to results
especially when using predefined capture
formats
for this purpose beerco offers
ready-to-use capture kits for antibodies
from different species
like mouse or human we provide
pre-established assay methods for large
number of pairwise antibody testing
that guarantees a fast learning curve
also for new users the sensor chip
surfaces thereby
can be used multiple times which lowers
the running cost for such an assay
and the antibodies investigated can be
applied directly from hybridoma
supernatants
so there is no risk of damage during
purification
and a shorter time to decision which
allows less budget spent on keeping
unnecessary clones and culture
the setup looks like this the capture
antibody from our capture kits
is immobilized on the surface or you can
even use pre-immobilized ones
the first antibody from your pair is
captured here on the surface the other
binding site is blocked
and then the antigen is injected binding
here to the first antibody
the second antibody can only bind
when it shows when it when it shows a
binding
when it reacts with another epitope
on this antigen
then the whole complex is removed and
you have a free surface again
to inject the next antibody pair which
should be investigated
and you can observe all these
interactions
in the corresponding sensogram so first
you have the baseline here then you have
the injection of the first antibody
blocking antigen and second antibody
and for each of these interaction you
can also observe
if they are less or very stable
in addition to the predefined methods we
offer an
intuitive software for streamlined
evaluation support of epitope binning
data
this software runs on our most actual
high throughput instrument platforms
like biocore 8k
plus biocore 8k and also the data from
biocore t200 can be investigated in this
software
here you see the most important
evaluation items
for an epitope winning experiment
so this here is the sensogram overlay of
all interactions binding of the second
antibody and here you can set
cut-off lines very easily just by moving
them
so it's a very interactive tool and from
from these results here the so-called
heat map will be generated
indicating the antibodies
which recognize the same epitope here
indicated in red
and the ones which will recognize
different epitopes
and from these results the binning wheel
is created which indicates the relation
and connection of all identified bins
on the investigated antigen
now i will show you how beer core can be
used for quantification of binding
activity
and the first example you will see how a
direct determination
of active protein concentration in
complex samples like plasma
could look like the default essay format
for diagnostics using bio
systems is in most cases a direct
binding essay
so here you see the detector antibody
immobilized on the sensor chip surface
the sample containing the analyte is
passing over that surface
and binding to the detector can then be
measured
here you see the principle of a biocore
concentration analysis in real time
this is the essay design so on the
sensor chip
the detector antibody is immobilized on
a three-dimensional dextran matrix
this is chosen because also if
immobilized the antibody molecule
remains flexible on this deck strain and
we have a three-dimensional surface so
the capacity here
for detector antibodies is much higher
this will lead
to a much more sensitive
detection range the sample is passing
over that surface
and only the antigens which are
recognized here by these antibodies
gives a response because only they bind
to the surface
you see here the corresponding
sensograms from a constant
from a calibration curve so here
this this is an overlay of the the
different concentrations
injected here with increasing
concentration the signal increases
and here these complexes which are
formed are very stable
to get rid of them because we want
always to reuse the surface
the samples are regenerated with a ph
high ph or high salt shift
and the complexes are opened
and the sensograms are done
back to baseline so we have an empty
surface again
so what you see here are increasing
concentrations and then for each
concentration
the report point the response is taken
at the defined
time point and this response
is then plotted against the given
concentration of the standard
and you get here these standard curves
an unknown sample is the responses
measured
from the sensorgram at the same time
like for the standard
and this response then tells us with the
calibration curve
how much concentration is in that sample
as an exemplary quantification i
chose this biocore igg subclass
distribution
essay which was designed for a human igg
production process
when igg used for intravenous
administration
the igg subclass distribution needs to
be determined
in this essay on the four flow cells of
a biocor t200 system
antibodies recognizing the different
subtypes like itt1
igg2 igg3 were immobilized
and the diluted plasma sample
was passing over all flow cell cells
in a row so giving four different
concentration results in one them from
one sample injection
this table depicts the standard which
was used and
uh this showed uh the same distribution
as
it would be expected in human igd
in typical human igg
here you see the standard curves for
each idg subclass
obtained simultaneously with the
different detectors immobilized here on
the different flow cells
these are overlays of the sensograms for
the different
calibration concentration and the report
points
here are taken to create
the calibration curves depicted here
concentration against relative response
and you see some of the this interaction
here is very very stable over the whole
run of the experiment so you see
all calibrations curve for more or less
exactly overlaying
for other detectors
their stability is not that well as this
one
so you see a drop in activity with
lowering signals in the calibration
curves
over the run of the analysis
but this is no problem for biocore data
evaluation software
as it can compensate for these effects
for very stable assays like the total
igg concentration determined here
the detectors show a high level of asset
stability and robustness
so as you see here this is total igg
determination and these are the
standard curves over the run
of the essay and also measured at
different
time days so day one day five and day
nine
and you see they're almost overlapping
they're all run on the same surface and
still
no activity loss can be observed
so such an excellent essay stability
enabled the use of a master standard
curve
and results for the production could be
observed at line
in less than 10 minutes per sample
here you see how thousand cycle runs
are looking in one plot combined
together
the red dots here are the calibration
curves over the run of these
experiments the green are the controls
and the blue
are the samples which have been measured
and you see the samples
and when it's a repeated sample it was
had a cv
of 1.3 percent over these thousand
cycle runs so when
when you are lucky and you have a very
stable detector and a
properly established assay you can use
it for
very long time it's very cost efficient
and
finally i show you this bureaucra essay
for quantitation of
influenza virus here an inhibition
format was used
for such an essay the respective
influenza hemoglobin protein was
immobilized on the sensor surface
in the sample a defined concentration of
the detector molecule
which is here an anti-ha antibody
is pre-incubated with the sample
if there's a low number of virus
particles
a high concentration of detector
molecules
is still present in the sample and they
are able to bind to the surface
giving a high response when a high
number
a high virus theta is present in your
sample
most of the detector molecules are bound
to the virus particles
and just a few can bind to the sensor
surface
giving resulting just in a very low
response
and this is how such typical sensor
grams look like so you
see here the sensogram in red there's
just a very low amount of virus standard
so there's a lot of detector molecule
binding to the surface
and when you increase the virus theta
you
get most of the detector molecules bind
to the virus
and just a low response signal is
observed
a typical inhibition essay
here you see a combined assay to
quantify three flu viral strains
at a time represented in a vaccine dose
so the setup was as follows you have one
empty flow cell for control
and then on this on these three flow
cells
the different viral strain antigens were
immobilized
the virus sample the vaccine sample
was then passed over all flow cells in a
raw
and you got these inhibition curves for
the standards
in parallel the interesting of this
essay was that the the vaccine producing
company
initially just measured concentration
of the different strains in their
vaccine with an
srid assay shown here with the red bars
this line here indicates the essential
concentration which should be included
in the vaccine dose
and indicated in blue here these are the
results of the biacore measurement
and you can see that for the strain b
the vaccine dose was significantly
overfilled
and by knowing this then later on this
company
could save a lot of this recombinant
material
and more doses could be
produced with the same amount
of vaccine
with the first part of my talk i
hopefully convinced you that biacore spr
analysis
is a valuable tool on the selection of
detectors
for diagnostic assays
a fast and reliable selection of
detector molecules
which show exactly the kinetic behavior
which is advantages for your diagnostics
is possible with biocore assays
you can determine the specificity
and epitope recognition on the antigen
to be diagnosed
it is also possible to predict
robustness of the detector binding
over a range of environmental conditions
and
in complex samples
observing the active concentration of
your detector molecule
with the biocore assay during production
purification
and storage allows you to define protein
concentration
needed for diagnostic assay production
resulting in
lower lot to lot variability
so you can optimize process and storage
conditions
for your respective detector antibody
generally just one interaction essay
needs to be established for all
analytics
on an individual detector molecule
in the second part of my talk you have
seen examples verbiacore sbr analysis
was employed as a direct diagnostic tool
to save asset time and sample material
a direct and specific analysis with low
amounts of complex samples is possible
because biacore microfluidics allow
working with low
sample volumes to save rare liquids like
patient or animal serum
several interactions can be observed
simultaneously
with the identical sample saving sample
material and
essay preparation time
taking into account the higher
reproducibility
less hands-on time less hands-on and
essay time
of a biocore analysis it is
significantly advantageous over the
broadly employed elisa format essays
so i hope you agree with me that biacore
instruments provide a versatile
multifunctional analytical tool to
assist your
selection of the perfect detector
molecule
or to make use of biocore instruments to
run
directly automatic diagnostic essays
with this i will end my presentation and
thank the audience for your kind
attention
thank you anya for that excellent
presentation we will now move into the
live q a portion of our
presentation as a reminder to our
audience please submit your questions
via the q
a box okay anya our first question
is let's see we have some great
questions coming in
let's start with this one to determine
antibody concentration
i use od 280 and hplc via protein
a affinity column what is the advantage
of using the bio core system
yeah so thanks this is a good question
because what's typically done is to
determine
concentration of iggs via protein a
columns because it tells us how much
active and functional antibodies are in
the solution
but this is just determine binding
via the fc part the huge advantage which
you could have
in addition to such a measurement which
you could also do in a biocore essay
you can immobilize the respective
antigen of the antibody
so such a binding will show you how
um what what the real activity what you
would need for your further as a
development and to observe the stability
of your antibodies as this is something
which
is the individual function of of the
respective antibody you will investigate
and in our systems as you have seen the
presentation before
you will be able to measure for example
the binding of the fc part look how much
properly folded antibodies are in your
sample solution
and on another flow cell determine the
antigen binding activity
which is often much more sensitive also
than the fc part which is the most
stable part of an antibody
so this um the antigen binding is
what you're really interested um when
you
look at storage conditions or
stability during purification or
whatever else
could be interesting also then how it
works
in your future essay
thank you now anya an example from
biomedical diagnostics institute you
show
eight different scfe
fragments screened per assay cycle
how many parameters or reagent
candidates can be tested in parallel
oh this is also a good question so in
our typical
biacore 8 play instruments you can
always
run eight different single chain
fragments tested in parallel
so you can capture them eight different
and then
run your sample over them and i have
once
did a calculation for an
hda screening for a customer of mine and
so here we we calculated that for
example
when to screen to 348
plates with with clone extracts um
but that what they get from their phage
display
um when you just capture it for one
minute and then
do a screen as i had showed the similar
one with one antigen concentration
such a measurement can be done without
any
hands-on and it will run 20 hours
if you do the same screening um
with capture and then directly look for
kinetics of these
fragments then with three concentration
and the single cycle screen you could
get these results in 27 hours and
then it's very easy to evaluate them so
it's really a possibility already for
your initial screen directly from the
extract
to run it in vehicle systems
excellent now next question it's a few
parts so bear with me here
i develop lateral flow assays kits
the membranes often contain or require
antiotic suffectants to help make the
membrane hydrophilic
and help proteins bind to the membrane
however surfactants denature proteins
and can destroy the antigen binding
sites of some monoclonals
making them non-usable in a lateral flow
assay
being able to identify candidates that
exhibit this behavior early is therefore
an advantage
can biacore be used to screen detergents
surfactants and to monitor impact on
antibody
and antigen binding
oh thanks for this question yeah this is
really uh
interesting and uh we have the
possibility
so similar to what what i showed in the
presentation where they
uh measured binding under different ph
and soul concentration just by changing
the running buffer
we also have an opportunity in our beer
core
8k systems and also in vehicle s200
to test um a lot of different
conditions um for for the binding itself
so um we have a functionality which is
called aba
where you can inject the sample
under significantly different conditions
so
the sample injection which comes to your
binding
will be can be designed under
different soul different detergent as
you would be interesting
and so by this you can in a predefined
method you can
test up to 96
different conditions in one run
and look how it will influence the
specific binding
so this is a very easy way if if if you
want to get
information on this test the binding as
the functionality of your antibody with
the antigen which should be
tested in your lateral flow essay
and then just vary the condition
whatever additives you need to test
you can add them and then observe
how they influence if they influence at
all
this specific antibody you aim for
or then you could look for set the
conditions you want to have for example
in your running buff already
and then do the screening of your
antibodies under such conditions
so then you can directly identify which
might be the ones
which will work later on in your test
kit
great thank you anya now a time for
maybe two more questions but i do want
to remind our audience that any
questions we are unable to answer
during our live event today they will be
answered via email
following the live presentation okay
let's
let's go with this one which sample
volumes do you need for an analysis
oh yeah this is a good question and
maybe also in comparison
to other essays very interesting so um
as an example for where i showed the
analysis in the biacore t200
for such a concentration measurement you
will need
40 to 80 microliter of your sample
for for one to five minutes injection
and it doesn't matter if you just
investigate this one analysis or if you
directly investigate four different
interactions
as if the sample passes over all
surfaces will be the identical solution
and giving you one or up to four
different interaction results
great and anya let's wrap with this
question
isn't there a risk of clogging of this
microfluidic system when working with
crude sample extracts
or plasma this is an understandable
um yeah problem you might think of
but we really have a lot of experience
with handling samples
these complex samples like plasma and
all our instruments have predefined
maintenance procedures
already programmed in the instrument
control software
which reminds you that that they need to
have a cleaning and so this is all
predefined protocols
and in addition for handling samples for
example we have also a lot of
lab guys and protocols so we have
experienced with what are the right
washing solutions to be um
when when you're working with sticky
samples like like plasma
and you can get all these protocols so
just contact
us we will we were really happy to
support you
in this handling and this is nothing you
need to fear of um there have been
really a lot of these studies done
there's also
already published results on this and
we can guarantee that um you will make
it and
don't need to worry
thank you anya now it does look like we
are out of time
but i want to tell our audience to not
worry any of those questions that were
submitted that we were not able to
answer today
and we'll be addressing them via email
anya thank you again for your time today
and thank you to the audience for your
great questions
today's presentation will be available
for on-demand viewing for 12 months
so please remember to share this with
your colleagues who may be interested in
today's topic
and don't miss out on the other
presentations on our agenda visit the
agenda tab
in the auditorium for a full listing
thank you again for your participation
and until next time have a great day bye